great H thanks for the invitation it's
really a pleasure to be here uh so as
you know the Simons is running these two
programs in parallel this term one on
polinomial systems or or I guess
algebraic geometry and complexity and
the other one on on graph Theory so this
talk is a little bit of both I mean
there's as we're going to see some
interesting things that relate
polinomial systems with graphs and I'll
try to explain a little bit what this is
so everything I'll say is joint work is
really the work of my studento santes
and I'll mention a few things about this
uh so let me start kind of perhaps very
quickly with somehow what the theme of
this is which is let's imagine that I
have a polinomial system that I'm
interested in solving so I have M
equations in here in N variables and
what we're going to do is we're going to
associate to my system of equations a
graph and somehow the way that we're
going to construct this graph is pretty
simple and pretty natural so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take each
equation I'm going to look which
variables appear in each equation I'm
going to draw a click
for each uh for for for that set of
variables so simple example let's
imagine that this is my set of
generators in here so my first generator
in here has a a variable 0 1 and two so
I'll just put a click this triangle in
here between variabl 0 1 and two I'll do
the same thing for my second generator
one and two this gives me the edge that
I already had and the same thing I do
for the other on and I obtain this nice
graph over here so if you want I'm just
abstracting some combinatorial
properties of the of my polinomial
system just into the
graph so in a sense what's interesting
about this is that I only retain
information of who which variable is
talking to which variable and that's
really the only thing that this graph
knows and there's a lot of very natural
questions that can ask in this situation
so to what extent the structure of this
graph actually helps me to solve this
system of equations and of course I put
solve in there emphasiz or in quotation
Mar there's many Notions of what do we
mean by solving a poal system for
instance let's say perhaps closer to
this talk is let's say that I want to
compute the grar bases or perhaps I want
to do something better than the grar
Basis something different to what extent
I can do operations in here that will
preserve the structure the sparsity in
particular of this graph imagine that
this graph is extremely sparse and I
don't want to like know new pols to
appear that mix all my variables I
really want to keep things Spar to some
exent and somehow of course complexity
questions I mean to what extent perhaps
this graph is nice then this will allow
me to solve things in
this is a huge subject I mean somehow
this is something that people have
looked in a variety of of subjects not
necessarily in in algebraic geometry but
in many many different florks so if
you're coming for numerical linear
algebra you've seen this many many times
I mean the structure of for instance
Matrix when you do AIS factorization you
factor yeah so just quick I should asked
so you don't allow multiple bonds if
they I don't care in this in this
version I don't care I just write the
graph there's more sophisticated
versions with put hyper graphs you can
overlo this in whatever way you want
here I'm just Zer right and saying this
appears in numerical linear algebra and
graphical models statistical graphical
models is a huge subject called
graphical models there's a beautiful
area called constraint satisfaction that
sometime you study General constraints
between variables and somehow these same
kind of things data Theory and sometime
that's common to all these are something
that has appear unifying notion for all
this stuff is is cordal the not of
cality and notion of tre with and I'll
explain what those is at least I give
you a crash course in two minutes and
there's a lot of names Associated to
this depending on which Community you
like in particular I guess closer to the
math side of course graph minor project
all the Roberts on SE more stuff
actually paper two the second of the 22
papers that they wrote with the title
graph miners is exactly about the
algorithmic consequences of having small
Tri right but again there's and I'll
tell you I'll condense in one one
sentence if you want the content of like
know this 20 years of
work so remarkably and at least for us
it was kind of interesting that we
haven't seen really work on on
competition for solving polinomial
equations that explodes the structure
and if I'm wrong please tell me and we
looked all over the place and what we
hope I mean really is that this is a
starting point to change this I mean
there's a lot of very interesting work
that comes out of essentially all the
mantras if you want that people have
worked in in here and what do we want to
see what extent this can be done in this
case well I think there's something I
mean people know this better say but
there's something triangular sets or
some sort of reduction you get something
in a form this this is my more refined
version this is this refin understand
that's the only thing that I can yeah
okay so what's IDE of cordal cality is a
very simple property of the graph
there's many many different ways of
defining them let me Define the way
that's going to be appropriate for me
which is idea that we're going to have a
graph I'm going just like before I'm
going to index my variables from x0 to X
these are my variables and then we're
going to define a notion this is
standard stuff I mean this is not our
work of course there's a Vertex ordering
we're going to order the vertex in a
particular way and if we're going to
call this ordering a perfect elimination
order and if the following property is
true ignore what it says over there but
the idea is I look at my variable Excel
I look at all the neighbors of Excel and
those have to form a
click so then I take this ver out I
remove it and I do it again I try to
find another variable my second variable
all the things that are connected to
that one they will have to form a click
and then I take it out and I keep going
and if I can do this for all my
variables this defines a perfect
elimination ordering and a graph is
cordal if and only if it has a perfect
ination there's other ways of find
finding it but this is
nice right so again zero thorder model
cordal is a nice property
graph now what do I do if my graph is
not cordal I complete it I do a cordal
completion I add edges in such a way
that it will be cordal and I assign a
parameter called the tree width which is
going to be the size of the largest
click that appears in that cordal
completion right again digesting this
for the very first time is difficult so
there's one picture that I wanted to
have in mind which is the following tree
width is a parameter of a graph and
somehow can think of a classification of
my graphs where in here I have Tre with
equal to one and Tre with equal to one
are exactly the trees or forests if you
want unions of trees all the way on the
other side if the tree with is equal to
n minus one what I have is a click a
complete graph in N
vertices and somewhere in the middle the
tree WID can have different parameters
in particular for instance if I have a
grid the GD graph this has threee with
whoops square root of
n when N is a number of notes there's a
nice parameter that somehow quantifies
if you want how close is my graph to
being tree like or being like a complete
graph is there a unique
smallest yes comping that is empty hard
but I mean and foral reasons just
because everything is
finite but it's not unique it's not
unique no no it's not unique
take ccle any
triangle the boundary of the number is
unique
yeah why we care about this because
again if I want to condense his 25 30
years of work in one sentence the idea
is that EMP complete problems that you
do on cordal graphs or sorry on graphs
of small tree with they become
polinomial time
horable the idea is if you want to do
stable set whatever you want learn how
kind of coloring whatever you want and
you do it on graphs of this type and
again of course one needs to quantify
them then they become for fixed tree
width they become polinomial time in the
number of vertices or even linear times
is there upper bound on the tree width
of a planer graph uh yes uh yeah they
bounds uh essentially I think for planer
graphs you get something like
Square this is essentially op for
example your last tap you crack up any
any any issue of sign General Street m
that'll be one or two papers on Tre
without I
mean whole graphical models is about
this I mean this appears over so great
you know you learn about this first
things that you want to do let's solve
poal systems let's try to apply this to
Sol poal systems perhaps we can obtain
some nice result and it's more subtle
than this so is that even for
instance if I look at so let me take the
subset some problem right I get integers
this is a problem of can I find the
subset that adds up to a number right
it's very easy to write the polinomial
system like this one the S are the
partial sums in
there the graph Associated to my
equations so here in my equations we
either have a zero as n or a variable
talks to its neighbor right so the
structure of the graph the graph that I
defined before that I is exactly a
path but we know paths have three with
one there trees but of course subset sum
is empty
complete so somehow it's not quite true
this meta theorem that I was telling you
before when you look at Pol equation
things are a littleit more sub or
there's things that have to be true for
something like this to
to and it's a little also wor I me give
you all the bad news at the same time is
that somehow in the linear situation is
also very different from the polinomial
case right because in the linear
equations somehow it's very it's easy to
do elimination in a way that preserves
graph structure that's exactly a notion
of perfect elimination ordering that I
can do elimination and somehow I don't
increase the sparcity somehow a graph
but for pols if you try to do many
natural things and Computing gr bases
that will destroy cality immediately so
simple example by Illuminating let me
take these two polom equations x0 talks
to X2 X2 and X1 are talking to each
other and the point is if I compute any
grer basis respect to any term order
whatever you want then that will always
contain the polinomial x0 - X1 so any
grar basis destroys the structure of the
graph I cannot hope to compute the gr
basis with the same structure of the
graphic there's no such
thing so perhaps we need to change
things a
bit good news so the good news or then
this is essentially the content of the
this paper that we're finishing this is
really the master thesis of ofgo which
is on the one hand to propose a COR
elimination algorith an elimination
algorithm that takes into account this
graphical structure and will allow us to
say some interesting things we're going
to be conditions I mean as we said
before in the full case things don't
work or we have to be careful so we're
going to put conditions under which this
kind of cordal scheme succeeds computes
what we want and it's in nice
way as a replacement of grer bases we're
going to be Computing I mean we could
compute Gro basis but that's somehow the
wrong object to compute in this case
we're going to compute the elimination
IDE of a maximum clicks somehow that is
really the nice object or a nicer object
and I try to explain quickly why is that
the case and as a result of this I mean
very much in line with the kind of
results that we were saying before is
that for a certain class of problems
we're going to have the complexity of
for instance Computing Bas this is going
to be linear in the number of variables
although it's going to be exponential in
the tri withd which again is very much
along the lines of all these results
that you were saying before all the
things in graphical models all the
things in you know kind of all over the
place you pay a price for tree with
clicks are really the problem and the
number of variables is not really such
big a deal because you can schedule
computations in a way that know kind of
the number of variables affects you only
lar and I'll talk a little bit about
implementation experimental results
right so again I have 10 minutes I'll
spend two minutes
each
so what's the idea of or the sketch if
you want of how Coral elimination works
is to some extent the natural thing that
you would do but you have to be careful
with a number of things and I don't have
time in here to tell you about the
subties but the basic idea is really the
following what they going to do is just
imagine that you're Computing the
elimination ideal so how you would
compute the successive elimination ideal
remember I have a perfect elimination
ordering I have my graph that's coming
from a pomal system I will compute the
cordal completion this cordal completion
has perfect elimination order which is
tailored to my polinomial system right
it's not any elimination order it's a
particular so we're going to produce a
sequence of ideals in there think about
them as the elimination ideals but
they're not quite like that and the way
that we're going to compute them is in
the following way at stage I let's say
that I want to eliminate variable X of L
so what I'm going to do is the following
I'm going to split my ideal into what or
the generators of my idea into all the
ones that contain X and all the things
in the click of
XL that's what we put in J in here and K
is all the remaining stuff all the stuff
that has variables in here and perhaps
some of these on and then I will just
eliminate again this is a cartoon
version I will just eliminate from this
EXO bar so essentially I get rid of this
and of course because of
cality the the pols that result in there
they only contain things in this
click right I mean that's exactly the
property of cority when I eliminate this
somehow I shortcut all the things and I
just have polins in here so what's
important at this point is that the
graph structure is preserved as I move
from one ideal to the next I don't make
the graph sparser sorry I don't make the
graph denser I keep the sparsity of
the right now if you just try to do this
then it doesn't necessarily work I mean
so there's conditions of course that we
will need to put for this to succeed by
succeed I mean that the the essentially
that I'm Computing the right V the right
variety up to actually the right variety
the right projections and the variety
and let me give again I don't have time
to tell you the specific details but for
instance there's one class of results
that we can write where for instance we
can put some zero dimensionality
assumption on the projections on the
maximal clicks again some technical
condition don't worry too much about
this but in particular this is always
satisfied for finite fields or 01
problem some condition essentially think
about as zero dimensionality and in this
case this method of eliminating things
will actually work and we have a
slightly different version actually more
General version that does not rely on
zero dimensionality but it relies on the
structural property of my generators if
might we call it simplicial and again
somehow
it's a property about somehow terms
having a particular type the leading
terms having a particular type and in
that case again which is not about
zero zero dimensionality we have again
that these corations exist what's a high
level idea how does one prove these kind
of things or why these things work so
they really have is
somehow the iterated version and
iterated version of the closure
extension theorem that you learned right
know when you first learn algebra
geometry computation Al geometry how to
extend a partial solution to a full
solution whenever you eliminated some of
the variables right that you need some
leading coefficients to be not zero and
the difference in here is that you don't
need to do it once but you need to do it
in an interative way and somehow that's
what this kind of conditions came into
place and cality that's the other second
piece that will tell us that we can do
this in a way that will preserve the
structure so again high level version
there's this cor elimination under
certain conditions what you compute is
exactly the right thing up to
again in the general case if we don't
put assumptions it may fail there simple
examples that will show this and if we
have time in the end I can come back to
this think about this as one result
about zero dimensionality the other one
it relaxes zero dimensionality we still
put some conditions on my poal system
that will guarantee that this kind of
iterated thing will work will compute
the right thing preserving structure all
the way to the
end
sorry in here no no in here I'm not
working over 01 or anything like this
and this is
not no it's a little bit different I
think it's not I mean it looks like the
condition for zero dimensionality but
it's not that's that for every variable
there's a living term yeah this is a bit
different because you require this for
the generators not
for not for a gra basis
um okay
so what about I said perhaps grer basis
we I mean at least in some of these
cases we don't like them or or they're
kind of somewhat problematic because
they destroy cality and the question is
can we do something nearly as good and
try to preserve as much as possible the
graph structure again think about the
situation where we have extremely sparse
graphs for instance and I don't really
want to like know mess mess it up in a
particular way so turns out or what you
would like to do is to compute the
elimination ideas for the maximal clicks
of My Graph and something that's very
nice about the cordal graph as oppos of
an arit I could try to do this for an
arbitary graph but they would be
problems and the two problems would be
that if you try to look at the maximum
clicks of an arbitary graph in general I
have exponentially many if you look at
an arbitary graph the number of maximal
clicks can be exponential cordal graphs
have at most n maximal clicks and the
other thing is that if you try to do
this an arbitrary graph you you run into
a local Global problem that you can
compute your the ideals for your clicks
for your individual clicks but then you
cannot glue them together and what
happens with cordal graphs is that
somehow again let me be very precise but
you don't have topological problems you
can glue this uh the maximal Clicks in a
particular way and call the tree the
composition that and somehow all these
Solutions will will come out nice and I
show an example example in just a second
right and why do we care about this
somehow this Union of the gr bases for
instance of the individual clicks has
nearly the same more information it's a
lot nicer it's a lot sparer and as I
said or I hinted we can compute these
maximal clicks from the output of this
Coral elimination algorithm and somehow
this is really the
inside that what happens in this case is
that instead of studying the variety
somehow in the full space what I really
want to understand are the coordinate
projections the projections on the
subspaces defined by the maximal clicks
and the cality structure allows me to
glue them in a nice way that I could not
do if we didn't have some kind of nice
property in that here's an example for
instance that will again at a high level
illustrate what I want to do so let's
imagine that I have this graph in here
this is described by these equations
right what these equations in code for
instance are just colorings of this uh
of this graph think about my graph it's
a blue one with without the green edges
right so that graph is not cordal we do
a cordal completion which is obtained by
adding this green things and now I have
a cordal
graph this graph I can just enumerate
the maximal clicks which we can do inal
time these are the maximum clicks of
this
graph and then what we can is compute
using something it doesn't matter what
the click elimination ideal are so these
are the elimination ideas where my
variables are restricted to the maximum
clicks so for instance this H5
corresponds to click number five and
what this is saying is that the
projection on my variables will give me
exactly this idea these are
exactly and what happens in here is that
for instance if I want to Let's imagine
that I want to solve the polinomial
system I can just solve independently
for each one of those ones all the
solutions I can glue them in a nice way
and cality tells me that I'll have have
a way of gluing them I will not run into
problem into any kind of problems and
again the theory of how to do this is
all this know Tre de compositions of
coral graph so that it's not terribly
complicated but the real point the
geometric picture I want you to have in
mind is that if I want to think of this
Variety in here all the colorings of
this graph I have a million points in
here right all the possible colorings in
there but there are projections on sets
of small size they're
small because when I look at every click
the size of that projection is at most
number of colorings for this number of
ARS right and it turns out that that's a
smart way of doing this and gluing
them okay uh I have one slide in
complexity and one slide on the
theoretical on the experimental results
so as I said somehow what we obtain
again very much in lines of know kind of
the theme if you want of tree with is
that in nice cases and I at least I'll
hand wve or exactly do we mean by nice
and here the complexity of doing all
this is linear in the number of
variables although it's going to be
exponential in the tree withd right so
in particular for instance the
complexity of finding the elimination
ideals in this case is going to be
exactly of the form o or this Heights um
polinomial terms in in in in the tree
with Kappa which is going to be linear
in n and exponential in uh in in the
tree with Kappa and in here Q is somehow
a parameter that determines how nice my
ADL is going to be again this is a
general version I haven't defined what
this is but if you want to make it very
concrete for a nice polinomial system of
the type that we've seen before we can
translate for instance we pick
particular polins into the statement
that if you want to count for instance
um the number of colorings of a
particular graph Q colorings if you want
to color a graph L know with C colors
then you can just count them exactly by
counting the solutions of a
corresponding polinomial system and that
will give you something which is again
linear in the number of variables and
exponential
so okay just a couple of things about
implementation so we imp Diego
implemented this in in Sage using
singular and this poly solver which is
really for for things over F2 in the
paper we analyze a few examples from
graph cing the one I described before
something from crypto and network
organizations whatever I only describe
in some level I think these
two so let me tell you what the this is
a particular example of a cry a baby
version of the What's called the the a
cryptos the advanced encryption standard
so this is a small or relatively small
polinomial system I think the largest
that we' solved in here has 288
variables and and 528 equations and
again ignore the numbers let me perhaps
we have more extensive tables in the
paper let me tell you what the high
level uh version is in here and this
implementation is not terribly optimized
I mean this is really
U so for small programs of course gr
basis will actually outperform the kind
of things that we can do just because
problems are not big enough that you can
start seeing the exponential versus
linear or small Behavior U but as you
the problems get bigger in this case for
instance for n is equal to 10 then cor
elimination scale is better I mean and
or or we see for instance that uh these
two methods for instance let's say
that um this one in here you need to
abort I mean we're aborting in here in
terms of memory and in here we really
don't have a problem and we could solve
I think much bigger things also there're
a lot more memory efficient because the
memory requirements that we have in here
they're bounded by the size of a maximum
click I mean that's really what bounds
so in a sense you don't depend in a very
sensitive way in number ofs the same
thing something quite similar is for the
so this was an example over
F2 if you do things over the rationals
in this case D did an example also based
on sens of networks we have nice
equations of this type I won't describe
them I think many of you have seen them
before there's kind of two regimes in
this case whether you're in the under
constraint situation or the over
constraint situation in the under
constraint regime what they're doing is
certainly better I mean doesn't even
make sense to compare it in the over
constraint regime the the methods are
competitive so this is just a plot of a
relative timings of one method versus
another method and as you can see again
we're in somehow in the bad regime for
us but even in here you know kind of the
timings I think fairly similar and
there's a number of instances in
particular that we can solve much much
better than these other methods again
it's not a complete analysis this was
really know just a start of trying to
see how well this methods work so I need
to wub up that's what they're telling me
so what's a summary this cordal
structure is an enormously theoretically
and practically interesting
uh feature of polinomial systems and and
we definitely need to exploit this if we
put the right assumptions which again
something that's very distinct from the
combinatorial situation is that we don't
need just tree with we need something
else about the geometry of these
problems I mean we have this way of
imposing this perhaps there's better
ways then Things become tractable it
yields practical algorithms they're
competitive with know techniques in a
relatively small of time and they're
implementable and actually those form
the core of you know kind of extremely
efficient methods for instance for
satisfiability or a whole bunch of other
areas and one of the things they're
trying to do is really to understand to
what extent one can extend this not just
to the groer situation or the
elimination type situation like we're
doing here but actually you do the full
spectrum of numerical methods for po
equations if you want to know more
Diego's thesis should be somewhere I
guess you can ask him and and also the
paper we hope to be H we're hoping to
get it before the talk it will be done
by the end of of this week otherwise it
can thank
you couple quick questions J when you
say you solve Click by
click so you have another ring of the C
to start for example you solve the first
click and then you have a variable which
intersect with the next click right so
you for the next click problem fix the
value that you found for the solution if
you want to solve yeah this is a
standard thing in in like kind of in
constraint satisfaction I mean that's
exactly what you do you propagate on the
click tree you know Click by click you
have to do it sequen you have to pick
any any ordering in particular if if you
pick an elimination ordering for from
the beginning this induces an an
ordering in the click tree so there's a
number of different ways of doing things
just saying you can't do all the click
problems individually SE different
processors at once if you want you could
do that but then you have to combine and
then you combine the solutions
independently I mean that you can also
do that yes I maybe you said that but
what's wrong with the equations for the
subset sums the ex that's a very good
question so what's wrong in here many
things right so first of
all remember I said that there's two
properties that we care about right so
the two properties are on the one hand I
Computing the right thing and in this
case this is fine if I just go in there
and eliminate one variable at a time
this is fine but the problem is that the
complexity of the ideal that I get in
the middle they get bigger and
bigger right so the projections if you
want on this varable on the partial sums
they're not bounded the projections in
here increase in
degree if I look only at for instance
for all possible assignments how large
can I know kind of S5 be then I have two
to the 15 possible values unless
something particular happens and one way
of doing this is exactly what you do
when you restrict the domain but notice
that in here my VAR are not 01 these s
have not 01 variables
right yes um in the problem of graph
coloring um you are describing a correct
I Wrong a an algorithm that is poal time
in um the number of vertices that where
the exponent depends upon the treatment
yep here and does this work for old
graphs are the conditions all graphs of
threee with less than or equal than sure
something yeah yeah um the the
conditions are actually met in this
particular case yeah yeah yeah all the
because that's essentially a Z1 problem
projecting down any particular ideal is
going to always give you some very small
set just
anyway you have a quick question yeah a
quick question I wonder do you have like
a family of problem family of polinomial
systems where we can show what happens
actually when looks at the structure and
then somehow the three wids is small and
then you there suddenly families
of I mean I mean there there's families
that you can treat I mean I know this
concept of treat but I wonder in this
context of um polom equation solving do
you have a like a family that you can do
so for instance and again I we're really
looking exactly at the something I can
understand I mean something with the
meaning so for instance I mean one thing
that happens in here uh when you look at
this these problems in here again we
need to check this but for what happens
when you look at these polinomial
systems the complexity of the um so you
have a graph somehow that depends on n
on the number of rounds of this crypto
system and the complexity in here seems
to be independent of end
so even though you're getting like you
know more and more rounds of the same
problem this is not affecting somehow
the this affects in an
exponential what am I trying to say um
yeah so you have a family of of
polinomial systems in here of and the
tree with is independent of them that's
exactly what I'm trying to say but my
understanding is you have like your
input system and is somehow Spar but
then sparity you you uh describe in a
more sophistic way using these ideas of
B three right then you have some other
conditions that you did not show and if
this condition if these three withs is
small then you can do it
efficiently
yeah again that by itself is very much
in line to I mean in a sense for the
discrete or the case we knew that I mean
we know we know this in the' 70s right '
80s yes that you know kind if you want
to do coloring if you want to do a
number of things of this type know kind
of I mean number of AR doesn't really
matter are the other conditions other
than tree with easily
detectable oh yeah yeah yeah you can
just check them yeah yeah yeah I mean
there conditions just on the input set
on on the inputs generator or the
generators of I and they're
automatically satisfied again this kind
of Zero Dimensional
situation okay to keep on schedule let's
thank
Pablo
and